well in a development that doesn't
really sound real and you couldn't
imagine might happen in the united
states of america we told you about it
earlier in the show the department of
homeland security a law enforcement
agency has decided to censor american
citizens who disagree with joe biden but
that's not their job it turns out their
job is not to destroy the first
amendment and threaten you to get you to
shut up their job is among other things
to protect our southern border but
they're not millions of illegal migrants
have already crossed and hundreds of
these migrants have gang affiliations
some are on a terror watch list
so congressman chipboy represents the
state of texas where most of this is
happening and he just questioned the
secretary of dhs alejandra mayorkas
about what the heck is going on here's
part of it
will you testify under oath right now do
we have operational control yes or no
yes we do we have operational control of
the borders yes we do and congressman we
are working towards what operational
control defined in this section the term
operational control means the prevention
of all unlawful entries into the united
states including entries by terrorists
other unlawful aliens instruments of
terrorism narcotics and other contraband
how about the dead bodies found by
migrants compassion
that was congressman chip roy of texas
who joins us congressman thanks so much
for coming on you seem you know there's
a lot of kabuki in these hearings you
seem genuinely upset
i am upset tucker uh look i represent
texas and i spend a lot of time down at
the border i was at del
del rio just about a month ago i was at
eagle pass just this monday
and i've talked to ranchers and i
watched a 65 year old rancher a tough
texan break down in tears because of
what's happening to his ranch finding
dead bodies of migrants on their ranch i
talked to people who have lost their
kids to fentanyl
and the impact that cartels are having
on the border and look if your blood
isn't clotted because of lord fauci then
your blood is boiling as an american
based on what you just saw from the
secretary of asylum and amnesty uh
alejandro mayorkas because that's what
he is he's allowing you know essentially
asylum to become the ex the exception
that swallows the rule of border
security and he's jamming through
millions of people to flood our borders
overwhelm border patrol and you the
american people your kids are the ones
that are getting hit by it the fentanyl
that's killing people in your schools
the ranches are getting overrun the
livestock that is dying the fact that
cartels are making tens of millions of
dollars and you know what he's doing in
the false name of compassion patting
himself on the back like a good liberal
compassionate liberalism you know what i
showed him pictures of body trailers the
mobile morgues that are in brooks county
texas where there's a hundred bodies
found he didn't even blink he didn't bat
an eye and don't apologize for my orcas
he knows what he's doing he's a formal
federal prosecutor the former head of
uscis a deputy
a dhs uh secretary he knows what he's
doing it's purposeful they're trying to
overrun our border overwhelm border
patrol in the name of asylum and the
american people have had it so we're
spending like 30 billion dollars in two
months to protect ukraine's borders
you'd think we'd be against invasions
where obviously for invasions if they
happen here did majorca say anything in
response like how did he how did he
answer your question
yeah all he said was that he was for
amnesty and that tells you a lot uh in
fact more than amnesty he's for
citizenship and that's a real tell and
he certainly didn't give a rip when i
said look mr secretary i've talked to
border patrol and i said you know what
there are a million people released last
year if i doubled your border patrol
budget tripled it quadrupled it would
that number go up or down and every
border patrol person i talked to in
texas they say letter bro go up why
because you're attracting more people to
come because you have people if you have
border patrol agents locked arm to arm
from mcgowan all the way to el paso if
your policies allow you to release a
million people you'll just release more
he knows it and he doesn't care that
that's empowering cartels and that's the
actual fact of what's going on and the
american people need to know that
secretary marcus doesn't care about you
he cares about flooding the zone here in
the united states and endangering
americans at a time when we have food
and energy shortages we're bringing in
two million new people illegally okay
tells you how they feel about our
country congressman chip roy of texas
appreciate you coming on tonight thank
you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight